[Music]
popcorn nobody of salt flasks of bourbon
and some Rolaids and everything I will
have hot dogs popcorn nachos whatever I
can get my hands on I like to sit middle
seats for sure not to close the screen I
love licorice but these days I've been
doing popcorn I like to sit smack dab in
the middle of the theater middle from
sides middle from front to back I just
can't do popcorn with just pop I got to
get a little something to counter it the
milk dud or sweetheart I like to sit in
the center row J some people let's go to
the back
what's wrong with you a lot of sit back
[Music]
basically anything that gets me really
messed up gummy worms regular M&M
skittles tropical skittles ours get
o'the cookie dough bites Red Vines Oreo
Muniz Raisinets popcorn white cherry
slushy
I generally spit on the right is of the
center section I'll see large popcorn
peanut M&Ms and I'm gonna dump them
inside and house a couple of hot dogs
I'm gonna get a large Diet Coke
my son and I we're gonna share the
popcorn and then he's gonna get mad when
he realizes the title says name rolled
in this guy's butterfingers baby roast
I'm enjoy cocoa chew I like Mike arune's
quite a lot I like Peter honey I like
some goobers I love a coca-cola some
popcorn maybe some ice cream I like to
sit towards the middle upper area were
you looking for like food I'm a puppet I
don't eat things I have been
indoctrinated to have to have popcorn at
movies and I know it's like nine dollars
for something that costs them 47 cents
but I just I have to have my movies just
go home
no caps bunch of crunch sour patch kids
mm-hmm and big league chew
goo and Milk Duds and did I say sugar
[Music]